-How are you, Emily?
-I'm great. How are you?
-I'm really good.
I'm very happy to have you here.
-So happy to be here.
-You have many accomplishments
I don't know if this count
as an accomplishment --
You have a huge
social media following.
-I think that --
-I do. I think it does, yeah
I didn't mean to undersell it,
but 25 million followers.
We have less on our show page.
-Oh, yeah.
-And don't take this
the wrong way.
I feel like my followers are -
-They interact more.
-They're more committed.
Yeah.
-They interact more.
-So, we had a challenge
backstage.
We each took a selfie...
-Yeah.
-...and posted it.
And we're just gonna check in to
see how many likes we each have.
So, here to take a look.
There's one we took, very nice
and I'm up to 499.
What do you got?
-I've got 90,000.
-90,000. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So, you might have
a Russian bot problem.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's --
Definitely.
They're coming for me.
-They're coming for you.
-They're coming for me.
-So, you have been engaged wit
politics for a very long time.
-You're a vocal
Bernie supporter.
You have your own clothing line,
and you have combined
the two in a way --
I don't think a lot of peopl
in the past have done this
for the politicians
that they love.
-This is true.
-You have a lot of Bernie wear
-That's in 2016.
-That's 2016.
You were an early adopter.
-Yes. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In your home state, actually
-I wanted to ask,
'cause you did --
You appeared at a New Hampshir
rally for Bernie.
-Yes. So, as you can see,
it was snowing quite heavily
I'm a California girl,
so it was a little bit
of a shock to the system.
Getting this photo
was a real commitment.
I was wearing, basically,
a giant fur jacket,
or down jacket.
And yeah, it was pretty --
It was interesting.
It was different,
and there were a lot,
a lot of people out for Bernie
even in 2016, even in the show
-You do Bernie events.
Bernie must be happy
that you have --
Here's one that I like here.
Rage Against the Machine.
There's a Bernie there.
-Yep.
I wear Bernie's face a lot
-You wear Bernie's face a lot.
-Has Bernie ever
returned the favor?
Has he ever walked around
with a Emily sweater?
-No, but I actually would like
you to bring that up to him.
-Yeah.
-If you could do me a favor?
-I mean, I feel like,
if he walked out
in a big old sweater
that said Emily on it,
that would be a lot of fun
-I mean, I would die.
-You would die.
-I would f-- faint.
He's like, Paul McCartney
or, like, some kind of
classic heartthrob for me,
but he's an older Jewish man
-Yeah.
-But, you know, whatever works
-Whatever works, yeah.
Your support of him,
which was --
I believe you first maybe
announced on social media --
led to a hashtag
that I don't think anybody
could have predicted when
they first saw Bernie Sanders.
The hashtag was, I believe
#hotgirlsforbernie.
-That's correct.
[ Laughter ]
-This was not something
you started, right?
-No. No.
-You sort of were the catalyst
for it.
-I think it was sort of
a response to this picture
-Okay. So here's
this picture again.
-Because I posted
my endorsement,
my video,
and then I posted this,
and you know, a lot of peopl
were like,
"Oh, you know, pretty girl
like, stay out of politics
stay in your lane,"
which I don't agree with.
I think we're all citizens
We should all be talking
about politics.
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I agree with that.
-Thank you.
And, you know,
I think it's a myth --
the Bernie bro myth,
and I think that a lot
of Bernie supporters
were like, "Hey,
we need to cancel this
Bernie bro, you know, hashta
with something new
and different,"
and sort of in response
to people's comments about
"Oh, stick to your lane,"
whatever,
#hotgirlsforbernie was born,
and now there's
a filter on Instagram
so you all can be hot girl
for Bernie, too.
-What does the filter do?
-Okay.
So it says one cheek,
"Hot Girls For"
and then the other one,
it says "Bernie Sanders."
Please put that on tonight
-Okay, well --
-Please.
-There you go.
You're a hot girl
for Bernie Sanders.
-Well, now --
I'll do anything it takes
to get more than
these 499 likes.
-Yeah, it's competition now.
-By the way,
it really hurt my feelings
that I said I had 499,
and then you said 90,000,
which means you just rounded
to the nearest thousand,
and I didn't even
have the confidence
to round up to 500.
[ Laughter ]
That's the difference
of the game.
-You kind of set yourself up
for this one.
-I'm gonna be totally
honest with you.
-I set myself up for failure
You know, obviously,
we're filming this
before the results tonight
-Yeah.
-And we don't know
how it's going to go.
You now having
supported Bernie Sanders
through two elections...
-Yeah.
-...even if he's not
the nominee, you must feel goo
about how he has
moved the party.
There are certain things -
outliers that Bernie
talked about four years ag
that are now considered
a little bit more centrist
to the party.
-Would you take that
as a victory,
if he is not the nominee?
-I mean, I think that
there's so much --
I'm actually doing an even
tomorrow with a bunch of women
I'm moderating a conversatio
with a bunch of women who
work on the Bernie campaign,
and one of the things
that we talked about --
because we obviously don't kno
what it's going
to look like tonight --
is that no one thought that,
you know,
making the party more left
having Bernie become the nominee
would be easy,
and I think, at one point,
everyone sort of thought
that was going to be true,
and we're still working.
We're still doing it,
and his politics and ideas are
so much larger than just him
So, yeah.
I do think that in the future,
even if it's not Bernie,
there is going to be
an incredible movement
that's been organized,
and that's really exciting